hey what's going on folks I want to
start off this video by thanking
everyone I really can't believe how many
of you actually came through and showed
your support and appreciation in my last
one in the last video I asked you guys
to like the video for me that way it
would help spread it to more people and
I almost didn't even post that video
because I thought people would just
dismiss it as [ __ ]
but with all the spoilers that have came
out I think most of you are more
open-minded to things and more at least
discuss it which is the main purpose for
me making these videos so since you guys
showed so much support I want to give
something back to show my appreciation
as well and most of you already know
about the giveaway on January 1st when
I'm going to randomly select a
subscriber and then send them any Game
of Thrones season on blu-ray that they
choose and most of you already know that
I'm going to do another giveaway right
after that which is going to be this
t-shirt but since you guys showed so
much love in that last video I'm going
to add a second gift to this next
giveaway which I will reveal this
weekend
so the second giveaway is going to have
two prizes and I'm going to just be
honest with you guys if you guys
continue to watch my videos and like the
videos I'll do a damn giveaway every
single month all you need to do is
subscribe and like the video and I will
randomly pick one of you every month and
send you a cool game of Thrones related
gift you guys do for me and I'm going to
do for you so thank you to everyone that
has participated now let's get today's
video started so just like I did with
the original leak and spoilers I want to
break it down and discuss what parts are
actually likely to happen based on
characters locations and motivations so
let's begin at the beginning it says the
White Walkers are marching south to the
wall and there is an undead polar bear
and a white Walker riding a giant ice
biter now I know the White Walkers are
definitely going to be heading south
there's no one left beyond the wall for
them to kill in Craster's dead so
there's no longer any babies for them to
be provided with so there really is a
much purpose for them to be north of the
wall now that everyone has fled south
but are they going to be riding on these
undead animals I don't think that's very
likely
the show tends to only spend money on
CGI when it is absolutely necessary
the direwolves are a very important part
of the story and they only tend to show
them when they are killing one of them
off so the chance of them using CGI to
show other animals probably won't happen
but there is always a possibility that
they could do it the show is winding
down to the end and I would like to
think they want to go out with a bang
and these animals have already been a
part of the story so I think that leaves
the door open for them to bring them
into the show we know old man told bran
the horror stories about the White
Walkers riding their packs of ice
spiders that were as big as hounds and
in the books there is a snow bear and
since we know they can raise dead horses
there's no reason why they couldn't
raise other dead animals so there is a
good chance they could go in this
direction I think it would be awesome as
hell to see but I'm not going to hold my
breath and expect to see you know what
woods on be polar bear and an ice spider
but it would be awesome to see don't get
me wrong ok brain and mirror have been
allowed through the wall edy tells bran
that John is at Winterfell and is now
king of the north bran doesn't tell Edie
about John's parentage but he does tell
Mira mirror tells brand that her father
Howland Reed once hinted that Rhaegar
and Lyanna loved each other
now unless everyone gets their armies
north of the wall immediately brain and
Meera have to get south at some point so
this part is obvious we know brain is
right outside the wall where the
weirwood tree is at right where the
Nights Watch take their vows and but
brain and Meera both know that the
night's king can locate bran with the
mark on his hand so now the time is of
the essence but they also both know that
his mark can destroy any magical
barriers that are in place to keep the
others out and Uncle Benjen just told
brain about the walls magical properties
so bran is going to have to make a tough
decision regardless knowing that his
mark could potentially allow the way
walkers through but I can't wait to see
how that plays out and also don't think
bran would tell Edie about John's
parentage
there is no reason he needs to know that
and if I were brand I wouldn't be
telling anyone because you never know
who once all the Targaryen is dead so I
wouldn't risk telling the wrong person
before I could at least tell John first
but I do understand
my brain would tell Mira she has helped
him this entire time so I think the
least he could do is tell her what the
hell has been going on and what he's
been seeing in all these visions plus he
should trust her by now he should trust
all the reeds and his vision he saw that
Howland Reed saved his father's life at
the Tower of joy so there's no reason
why I don't think he would trust Mira
with this information and I personally
believe that Rhaegar and Lyanna were in
love I do not think Rhaegar kidnapped
her I don't think there's any way in
hell I think they were both in love with
each other and I think Liana left with
him willingly all right next is John
Davos tormund Liana Sansa and Elise
Karstark and they're discussing what to
do with the castles last hearth the
dreadfort and karhold Liana wants the
castles to go to the loyal houses who
helped John but at least once John to
forgive the children of the Karstarks in
the umbers John does but he allows the
wildlings to take control of the
dreadfort now I can definitely see a
scene like this taking place John did
not have the support of everyone in the
north when it was time to fight and now
that he won the Battle of the bastards
in reclaimed Winterfell for his family I
can absolutely see some people having a
problem with those who didn't help
especially Lyanna Mormont she was
brutally honest and loyal and already
put everyone in their place right before
John was named king so I could
definitely see Leona having a problem
when it comes time for John to divide up
you know all the different lands in the
north I could see why she wouldn't want
the umbers and Karstarks to have any
piece of the pie but we know John always
wants to do what is right and not hold
everyone responsible for what others
have done or not done just like he done
with the wildlings but I agree that John
should give something to the wildlings
they have helped them in many ways and
saved his life in many ways so I think
they absolutely deserve something
especially tormund
I think Poorman should be given his own
house but I am a huge torment fan so I'm
always going to be biased in favor of
him I know they were once savages but I
don't blame them I know if someone kept
me out with a big-ass wall knowing me
and my family were starving and freezing
to death I'd be willing to murder people
too just to get to safety but that's
just my opinion
but I'm not sure if this scene will take
place or not I'd give it a fifty-fifty
chance I guess there hasn't really been
any evidence to show that this is going
to happen but it's really not a crazy
prediction I can see something like this
taking place okay Aria freeze ed mirror
from the phrase cells ed mirror is
depressed after getting the black fish
killed Aria tells him to retake Riverrun
since the phrase are dead I think we
will see something like this if you saw
my last video about Arya Stark you'd
know that I already predicted this to
happen we know Arya is on a mission to
wipe out all the phrase and we know that
ed mirror is still there locked up in
the cells and considering ed mirrors
family
I think Arya will free him while she is
that Walder Frey's but I wasn't sure if
ed Muir could legally take control of
the free army but if Arya wipes out
every living male Frey then there really
wouldn't be anyone to dispute it and if
I were ed mirror I would try and take
control of the twins
especially after what Walder Frey's put
him through all right Tyrion tells the
sand snakes that he is disgusted that
they murdered his own niece he tells
them that after Danny takes the throne
they are going to pay now I do not think
this is going to happen not in episode
one I think the sand snakes will be
taken prisoner by Euron in the first
episode and since Tyrion is on Danny's
ship and the sand snakes are on a
different ship there's really no way for
Tyrion to say this to them while they
are at sea and I think the sand snakes
will be captured at sea before anyone
reaches land so I highly doubt Tyrion
threatens them here I would absolutely
understand why he would we know Tyrion
and Marcella had a good relationship and
he would definitely be pissed that they
murdered her but I just don't see him
being in position to talk to them in the
first episode now Neela Costa Thorne
Yara's forces and Danny's split up Yara
heads toward the Iron Islands while Dani
heads towards Dragonstone and during all
this urines thousand ships are being
finished built so he head south I do
think Yara and Danny will split up
somehow we know from the spoilers that
Yara gets captured by your own and
think of yarra was sailing and Danny's
fleet during this then Danny would have
her dragons destroy her on before he
could leave so I definitely definitely
think Iran is going to have to catch
yara with her guard down and blindside
her without Danny's forces being around
I'm just not sure why your ax would head
right back to the Iron Islands after she
just left there though the only real
reason I could see Yara heading back is
if Danny would lend her some kind of
help to take out your on before his
ships are being built
I don't think Yara would go back and
take your on on with just the Ironborn
that she has I think she'd definitely
want to take a little extra support just
to take him on so I'm not sure if she
gets attacked while sailing back to the
Iron Islands but I do know she will get
attacked at the sea somewhere
Euron had those thousand ships built
pretty damn fast though but I guess
we're just going to have to assume that
they have been building them during the
off season of the show we're just going
to have to suspend disbelief on this one
but regardless of how it takes place we
already know you're on captures her in
the sand snakes regardless jaime and
cersei get into an argument
Cersei gets Jaime to forgive her and
they start having sex now I wouldn't be
surprised by this at all I would hope
that Jaime would leave this crazy [ __ ]
by now but we know he is completely
blinded by his love for her sister now I
know he's not happy with what she's done
because Jaime already killed one King
for wanting to burn the city down and
now that Cersei has done this which
ultimately caused their own son to
commit suicide
I would think Jaime would go apeshit but
thanks to the spoilers we know Jaime
does not abandon her right away if at
all we have already seen tons of leaked
photos that show Jaime leading the
Lannister army into battle and we've
also seen leaked photos that show Jaime
and Cersei together in King's Landing
so Jaime isn't going to leave her just
yet even if he is pissed in Cersei she
also knows Jaime's weakness which is her
so I could definitely see her using sex
as a tool to keep Jaime in line I think
as long as she keeps giving it up the
Jaime she can get away with anything she
wants and he's going to stay by her side
for now for now at least
all right bring in erisa Winterfell
after seeing the stark banners I can
only assume Breen is heading in this
direction she is sworn to protect Sansa
and last we saw Brian was sent to the
blackfish by sanso to try and get his
support for the upcoming war but we know
the blackfish declined the offer so
bringing in Podrick left and headed up
the river more than likely to return to
Sansa Brian probably has no idea that
they even won the war yet but once she
will see the stark banners at Winterfell
then it's going to be pretty damn
obvious I'm not sure if bran will arrive
during episode one but I do know she
will be back under the Starks roof as
soon as possible as long as she doesn't
run into someone along the way that may
want to kill her but even then it would
just slow her down because I think it's
going to take a goddamn army to stall
bran she's as tough as nails
it says Melisandre runaan's to the
Brotherhood without banners
Melisandre tells them that John is azor
Ahai so the Brotherhood without banners
decide to go to Winterfell now I could
also see something like this happening -
we know John sent Melisandre south after
he learned that she burned Princess
Shireen alive at the stake and we last
saw her leaving Winterfell for South and
along the way she could easily run into
the Brotherhood without banners I think
there are several different characters
Melisandre can run into along the way
which I did make a video about before
but we also know that the Hound
is with the Brotherhood without banners
and according to the leaked photos we
know that the Hound and corman will
definitely have scenes together next
season so assuming the Hound stays with
the Brotherhood and Corman stays with
Jon I think we will see all of these
guys together at some point next season
so I wouldn't rule that out at all next
Jorah arrives in Old Town I think this
is likely to happen at some point I
believe we know Danny sent Jorah on a
mission to cure his greyscale so he
could safely return to her and be by her
side when she goes to conquer Westeros
in as much as Jorah loves Dany at this
point I think he will do just that I
know whenever I come down with some type
of cold all I have to do is Google my
symptoms to figure out how to get better
and since the citadel was basically a
physical form of Google I see Jorah
doing the same knowing that if anywhere
has secure written it would be at the
Citadel so I think this will happen I
just don't know if it's going to happen
during episode one but we know there was
leaked photos already that showed Jorah
and Dany together on Dragonstone so we
have to assume that he definitely got
his greyscale cured at some point and it
probably is going to happen fairly early
because we see Jorah and john at
Dragonstone together and we can pretty
much assume John's going to be there in
episode 2 or 3 okay jaimé in the
Lannister army leave King's Landing to
go south to sack Highgarden Jamie takes
widow's wail with him now if you have
seen all the spoilers I have uploaded
previously you would know that all of
this will take place next season we have
already seen photos of Jaime carrying
widow's wail and we have already seen
photos of Jaime in the Lannister army
fighting against the Tyrells so there
really isn't anything for me to
contemplate here if I had to pick
something Jaime did just arrive in
King's Landing so if I had to dispute
anything it would be that he isn't going
to leave again in the very next episode
but who knows if they know Danny is
coming with this massive army then
they're going to want to gain support
and weaken her allies as much as they
can before the big war comes so that's
just my guess and this last part is
pretty obvious it says Danny arrives at
Dragonstone if you watch my other videos
you would already know my stance on this
we already know Dany has set sail for
Westeros and it's heading in this
direction and we have already seen
hundreds of photos showing Dany and
Tyrion on a beach of Dragonstone so this
isn't really any new information but it
also says Dany and Tyrion go into
Stannis his old war room and Dany turns
the Tyrion and says shall we begin now I
know Danny said this before so there was
always a chance she could say it again
and this could become like her new
little catchphrase sort of like how
Tyrion always says the Lannister always
pays his debts but I kind of doubt she
would say this again but who really
knows unless they saw that written on a
script somewhere I wouldn't have
predicted this myself but overlooking
all this new information
I think most of this is likely to happen
I just can't guarantee it will all
happen during episode 1 but most of the
characters are in position to do these
things so these aren't really any
groundbreaking predictions I could see
someone guessing this stuff most of it
already assumed what happened myself I
didn't think Jamie would go to
Highgarden so that is something I was
kind of surprised by but other than that
I think most of us assumed we would see
these things at some point but comment
below and give me your thoughts on this
first allegedly leaked episode and tell
me what you think is likely to happen in
episode 1 and as always thanks for
watching and supporting the videos and I
will see you guys in the comment section
bye